bonjour mathieu bolle-reddat merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
cet après midi donc la sncf dans le
rouge sans pour autant on appelait à
l'état quelle a été votre réaction à la
lecture de ce bilan par jean pierre
farandou chez nos confrères du figaro
reports d'investissements non
remplacement des départs à la retraite
prêts bancaires ont le faire un ministre
de l'économie avait sifflé la fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte maintenant c'est à
la sncf de se débrouiller tout seul
écoutez la sncf a été très gourmande en
argent public pendant l'ensemble de
cette période de crise sanitaire avec
énormément d'argent qui ont été versés
au titre du chômage partiel et on a mis
on met encore aujourd'hui des gens en
chômage partiel d'ailleurs en
ile-de-france à des agents de conduite
des agents commerciaux on a des gars qui
sont l'idée le soir alors qu'il ya
pourtant des trains est alors qu'il n'y
a plus aucune mesure sanitaire c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya plus ni confinement ni
obligation de télétravail de la part du
gouvernement donc les usagers sont
revenus à une ceinture en télétravail et
pourtant on a encore des jean jaurès
marcel aujourd'hui et qui touchent enfin
en touchent des aides de l'état les 700
ou douzaine de l'état pour ça donc
là-dessus vont pas me faire tuer le
mouchoir ce que je remarque c'est que
comme vous l'avez excellemment souligné
la direction prend prétexte de cette
crise sanitaire pour justifier des
milliers de suppressions de bosses qui
va y avoir en 2022 et les blancs les
plans sociaux sont en train de tomber
aujourd'hui dans les différentes
instances du personnel et je prends un
exemple tout simple un là il y en a un
qui tombe en ce moment même sur la ligne
l du transilien et qui prévoit la
suppression de plus de 20 % 20 % des
postes d'agents commerciaux c'est-à-dire
des gars qui seront vidés qui seront
désertés au détriment du service public
pour les usagers est il forcément il va
y avoir une riposte des cheminots par
rapport à cette ceni est là donc les
neiges c'est à dire une riposte des
cheminots par rapport à cette saignée ça
veut dire que vous allez manifester il
ya un appel à la grève qui est prévu
c'est ça bien sûr déjà contre les
suppressions de postes sur la ligne
rennes d'agents commerciaux le 9
novembre prochain mardi prochain alors
là ce couple rtl france un appel à la
grève de la cgt cheminots versailles
avec rassemblement devant la gare de
versailles à 10h pour envahir la
direction et faire entendre faire
entendre nos droits les droits des
cheminots dont les postes vont être
supprimés mais les droits de tous âges
et aussi parce que ce service public
ne sera pas assuré des emplois en moins
dans les gars et du service public en
moins pour les usagers c'est une
évidence mais comment la sncf peut-elle
survivre face à ses concurrents parce
que
c'est peut-être tout ça l'enjeu on sait
que la région paca est devenu récemment
la première région à mettre fin au
monopole de la sncf
il ya un gros enjeu qui qui s'annonce là
pour pour la sncf la sncf et c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il ya également les
cette restructuration
est en fait les cff n'a pas envie que
résister à la concurrence mais c'est
comme en paca
annonce qu'elle ne se portera candidat à
0 appel d'offres pour les lignes ter et
les transilien je suis même dire c'est
pas qu'une annonce est déjà une réalité
de liste en paca ya une ligne la ville
de nice je crois qui a été remporté par
le groupe est sincère mais les cheminots
seront quand même transférer une
entreprise privée puisque la sncf a
postulé non pas pour elle mais pour une
de ses filiales privées donc ce n'est
même pas une ouverture à la concurrence
c'est une privatisation c'est un jeune
père d'albert dans chaque ligne dure à
la concurrence soumises en médoc passera
une boîte privée qu'elle vienne du
entreprise concurrente qu'elle vienne
d'une filiale de la sncf donc ce
chantage à l'ouverture à la concurrence
pour justifier les suppressions de
postes aujourd'hui lg d'admissibles il
l'est d'autant plus que c'est de
l'argent public qui est donnée dans le
cadre des contrats de plan pour payer
des personnels en gare pour qu'ils aient
les trains qui circulent donc il ya
aucune raison aujourd'hui que malgré que
cet argent du but soit versée pour qu'il
y ait du personnel est un pur sucre du
personnel papa sombre mesures d'économie
financière
on a vu plusieurs opérations
communication du gouvernement pour la
la mise en valeur des voyages en trains
seulement un effet d'annoncé ou la
volonté est de donner la priorité au
transport ferroviaire sachant que jean
pierre farandou 1 dans le figaro cible
également la voiture comme principal
concurrent
oui mais en fait c'est très intéressant
ce numéro de pompier pyromane du
gouvernement 1 c'est à dire que c'est le
qui supprime par exemple le transport
par voie ferrée que tu des années un des
millions de tonnes kilomètres qui sont
passés du rail à la route de parler
politique gouvernementale et qui
aujourd'hui disent il faut remettre du
cher aux verts
amelio rapport modal en tout cas du
ferret par rapport aux rails c'est
monsieur macron je crois n'est pas tout
à fait un inconnu qui quand il est d'une
liste de l'économie a mis un terme au
monopole du rail sur un certain nombre
de deux lignes intercités afin d'y
les bus macro qui aujourd'hui
font un report modal aussi du rail vers
la route et donc qu'ils sont
responsables d'une plus grande empreinte
carbone des voyages du quotidien donc dû
dire au faire il ya un grand pas la cgt
depuis des années se bat pour excuser
moi pour
inverser la tendance c'est à dire qu'on
revienne à transporter pour le voyageur
et à transporter pour le marchandises se
bagarre sur tous les fronts là dessus et
encore aujourd'hui nous défendons cette
grande idée d'un service public
ferroviaire leur monopole public
ferroviaire au service des intérêts
populaires et des exigences
environnementales
merci match bolle-reddat d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général de la cgt
cheminots à versailles